Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
On December 17th, 1977,
Gary Gilmore was executed for murder.
He was the first prisoner executed
by the United States after a
10-year suspension of the practice.
When asked if he had any
last words, he simply replied
"let's do it."
Years later, advertising executive Dan Wieden
adapted those words into
a slogan, that is now more widely known
than Gary Gilmore.
Last words
are powerful.
They are the final statement, a person's entire life has
been leading up to.
One last chance to go on record
before obliteration.
We don't know Albert Einstein's
last words.
He spoke them in German
to a nurse who only knew English,
They're lost.
But what will be
our first words?
The first words
from earth extraterrestrials out there
might hear from us.
We have been broadcasting signals
with radio waves
wirelessly through the air for more than
one hundred years.
Under the right conditions,
those signals can leak into space
and keep going outward at the speed of light
through our galaxy, through the universe.
Current human technology would struggle
to tune into regular TV and radio broadcasts from
as near as Mars.
But perhaps other intelligent beings out there
would fare better and could point there
instruments at earth
and hear us.
If so, what would the
earliest thing be that they could receive?
Our cosmic first
words.
Well, the
earliest signal, robust enough to be
picked up light years away,
might have come from Hitler.
His 1936 broadcasting
of the Summer Olympics used powerful
enough radio equipment to reach
forty-one countries,
making it a contender for what listening
extraterrestrials could receive as,
to them, Earth's first words.
Within the last 50 years or so, broadcast signals
in general, have become stronger
than Hitler's Olympics
and are better candidates for being intercepted.
The earliest of them have traveled
50 light years away from Earth.
Altogether they have entertained billions of
people and by now about 2,000 stars.
The 133 brightest of which are shown
here.
So far, Martin Luther King JR's
"I have a dream" speech
has traveled as far as the furthest
on the diagram µAra, which has
four known planets.
In six years,
our first words on the Moon
will pass by µAra's
system.
"That's one small step for man,
one giant leap for mankind."
Those words were spoken by Neil
Armstrong,
seen here a few years before his death
with Eugene Cernan,
the most recent and currently
last man to have walked on the surface of the Moon.
On December 14th, 1972,
before climbing back into the lunar module,
Cernan spoke
our, as of today, last words on the Moon.
"We leave as we came and,
God willing, as we shall return, with peace,
and hope for all mankind."
Of course,
once inside the lunar module, the crew kept
talking, meaning that technically
the very last words humans have said
on the surface of the Moon were a
countdown spoken by Harrison
Jack Schmitt.
"Three, two, one."
We haven't been back to the Moon
since.
But hold on. What were the first words
spoken on the surface of the Moon
really?
Armstrong's giant
leap statement is a good answer,
but what counts as being
on the Moon if touchdown
counts? Then the first words spoken on the
Moon go not to Armstrong but to Buzz Aldrin,
who, on feeling at least one of the landing pads
softly settle onto the lunar soil, spoke
this immortal description:
"contact light."
We are pumping broadcasts in the space
as an ever expanding sphere of radio waves.
But here's something humbling.
Even while growing at the speed of light,
Earth's radio sphere is puny.
This is our galaxy, the Milky Way.
Comparatively,
the distance our radio signals, our voice
has traveled is this big.
The universe is huge.
How the heck are you supposed
to be remembered in it?
Utter last words that stick around after you die?
Well, you may have heard
the famous quote from Banksy
"They say you die twice.
One time when you stop breathing and a second time,
a bit later on, when somebody says your name
for the last time."
But your anonymous influence continues
long after that, right?
I mean, people may stop saying your name,
but, for instance, if you have kids and they have kids
and so on and so on, you continue on,
in a way.
Maybe just genetically, not by name.
Well, people have tried.
The world record
for most children passed
out of one single woman
belongs to Mrs. Feodor Vassilyev.
She had
16 pairs of twins, 7 sets of triplets
and 4 sets of quadruplets for a grand total
of 69 children.
As for being a biological
father, that takes less time.
The documented record
for most children fathered by one man is held
by Ismail Ibn Sharif, who is estimated to have had
more than 900 children with multiple women.
But children—or not—in a feedback system like
earth or life, cause-and-effect
are complicated and never ending.
Remember the double pendulums
from this video? A small difference
in the initial conditions of a system
can lead to enormously
different outcomes later.
On Tuesday
I'm flying from London to Los Angeles.
The plane will be flown by pilots who
can steer it toward the correct runway
in the United States, but if the airplane needed to be
aimed from London and sent on a straight shot,
now, things would need to be very specific.
Misaiming just one degree to the left
at the beginning would send
the plane not to Los Angeles
but nearly 160 kilometres south
to Tijuana, Mexico.
Your name and your last words might
eventually be forgotten, but your status
as an initial condition for the universe's
future is already happening.
Bach died before he could complete
The Art of Fugue.
The peace ends abruptly
during Contrapunctus XIV.
So, composers continue
reconstructing it.
For that reason, it is
uniquely alive.
Speaking new
last words all the time,
as new people meet it
and finish it in their own way.
Likewise, no matter how
cool or lame and small
you feel, you will continue.
Your impact will be remembered, mathematics
guarantees it.
Even if like Bach you leave things
unfinished.
And as always,
thanks for wa...